that's how much you'd be bigger jet
definitely little one as we begin our
journey into God of War fall and
exploring the mythology and lore behind
the game I'd like to start with a
character that we encounter very early
on a character who's first introduced to
us as the stranger now over the course
of the video we'll examine his true
identity
his role in the game compared to his
role in actual Norse mythology and
hopefully by the end we can discuss the
differences and the reasons for them we
first encountered the stranger
during somewhat of a father-son bonding
moment between a trace and Kratos when
there was a knock at the door the
stranger is almost golden Kratos - come
out and face him claiming that he knows
what Kratos really is with the Tres
unaware that his father is a god and
Kratos wanted to keep it that way he
goes to face the stranger after a series
of questions and backhanded insults from
the stranger the two finally come to
blows and we quickly find out that
whoever this stranger is he possesses
the power of a god and we are given a
few hints true in this first encounter
as to who the stranger could be he
mentioned several times that he's
incapable of feeling anything even
saying that he had hoped of all the
people he faced it would be Kratos that
would finally make him feel something
we'll given our biggest clue and he says
he was sent by Odin and what he wanted
was answers implying that he could be
one of the many sons of Odin this
confrontation eventually ends with the
two on the floor in a bloody mess and
Kratos snap in the strangest nick thrown
him down a large crack in the ground it
doesn't take too long before we actually
learn the true identity of the stranger
when observing a discussion between the
stranger and Mamere he confirms that he
is a son of Odin and his name is Boulder
after several more encounters crater
Sunnat Reyes learned the hard way that
border cannot be killed by any physical
magical source essentially making him
indestructible
now that we know who the stranger is in
the game we can compare and contrast
these depictions to those of actual
mythology Boulder was the son of the god
Odin and the Korres Frigg but in the
game his mother is Flair and here's
where it gets a tad confusing friggin
Freya in Norse and Germanic folklore are
sometimes regarded as two separate
entities and other times they appear is
the same person just with a different
name so I guess we can cut go to war
some slack of that one as the
relationship between friggin Freya is
fairly ambiguous even within mythology
so back to Boulder himself in Norse
mythology he was described as being
loved by all of those around him he was
said to be so handsome and gracious that
light would radiate from him not exactly
what we seen the God of War version one
day border began to dream about how he
would die and in his concerns he told
his mother who loved her son so dearly
as she traveled the entire world have
been everything swear an oath to never
harm her son with Boulder now invincible
the gods would often amuse themselves by
throwing weapons and random objects at
him only to see them bounce off of the
God completely unharmed we do also see
this in the game but instead boulders
mother with the use of magic makes it so
he cannot be killed however there is
quite a downside as Boulder is left
unable to feel anything in the side
effect of this spell does explain and
help us understand boulders character in
Norse mythology he was gracious and
cheerful but in order to create a
character who is the opposite of this
and essentially a villain for the story
the downside of his mother's spell
explains boulders behavior and mental
state with him left angry and resentful
towards her and his own existence if we
once again refer back to Norse mythology
Boulder does eventually die and it's at
the hands of Loki Loki as if fleek had
missed anything in her quest to obtain
an oath from everything in the world to
which she answers that she considered
mistletoe to be too small and harmless
to even ask for on earth Loki being the
trickster that he was then created a
spear made from mistletoe and convinced
the blind God Hodor to throw the spear
assuming that it will bounce straight
back off Boulder
but when Hoda threw the spear he threw
it with such force that it pierced the
God instantly killing him in the game
itself Balder is not killed by mistletoe
spear but when he punches a trace his
hand is pierced by a mistletoe arrow tip
which was being used to hold a trace as
quiver together
the mistletoe alone does not kill
Bordeaux but he now claims to be able to
feel pain so we can assume that the
mistletoe broke his mother's enchantment
leaving him vulnerable and he would
eventually be killed by kratos now
there's no denying that boulders
depiction in God of War differs
drastically to how he was seen in Norse
mythology he's almost shown as being the
exact opposite in some cases and some of
you may not like that but there is a
reason an explanation as to why it's
done when Boulder is first introduced to
us he comes across as a slightly
unhinged enormous drunken brawler type
as the story progresses so thought
dislike for Bordeaux as he assumes the
role of the villain but by the end of
the story we begin to understand his
issues with his interfer and mother and
the struggle of having to live a hundred
years without being able to feel
anything he becomes his corrupted figure
driven insane by what he perceives to be
his mother's curse I think it's fairly
normal to feel a degree of sympathy
towards Balder with his death being seen
as almost a release from the life that
he hated there are a few nice touches
and moments added throughout the game
that many people would have missed the
relationship between Boulder and his
overprotective mother is quite an
accurate representation of Boulder in
Norse mythology there are some accounts
that come from the Danish historian sack
so chromatic Asst that described Boulder
as a warlord constantly eager to engage
in battle and that's something that we
definitely see in the game with his
endless pursuit of Crater sand at Reyes
and the sheer number of battles between
them for those of you who would have
preferred to see Boulder die at the
hands of Loki we find out at the end of
the game that the name of traces mom
actually gave him was in fact Loki
meaning their way would remain somewhat
true to the original story with both
Loki and mistletoe playing a part in the
death of Boulder for everyone who was
sad to see Boulder die I wouldn't be too
disheartened because during Ragnarok he
does actually return to the land of the
living so there is a chance we see
Boulder make a return in a future court
of war game I hope you guys enjoyed this
style of comparison and exploration
video and if you did then feel free to
share any ideas or suggestions with me
in the comments below but as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained